Speaker 1: Let's try it drew from Fort
Lauderdale. Drew, you're on the air.
David, sir, oh, you're perfectly clear.
Yes. Hear me. Yeah. Nice. I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: OK, great. What's going on?
If Rittenhouse is found not guilty on all murder
charges, yes. What do you think the potential
backlash or reaction to the public will be?
Speaker 1: I want to be really careful because
I don't want to encourage any violence. But I
think there is a possibility of violence after
the verdict, no matter what the verdict is.
Speaker 3: Yes. I mean, I think regardless
of what happens, it will only further
divide and agitate us as a country. I mean.
Speaker 1: I I worry that that's the
case. I worry that that's the case,
and I hope that that doesn't happen.
Speaker 3: The other thing I worry
about is I believe Rittenhouse is
going to be the next MAGA senator.
Speaker 1: Right? Yeah, no, no. I think he
lands up in. This guy is going to be lionized
and made a hero. If he's found guilty, he will
be made a martyr. The right is just foaming
for a sort of Zimmerman like character. And I
think to be perfectly frank, I think Rittenhouse
is more sympathetic than Zimmerman was.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. Yeah, absolutely.
Speaker 3: And also is the
judge's last name, Schroeder?
Yes. Said any relation to Ricky Schroder.
Speaker 1: I have no idea who that is,
Speaker 3: Ricky Schroder is the Silver Spoons
kid. The actor who who is helping Rittenhouse
immediately after this. This all
Speaker 1: happened. Oh, I wasn't
paying much attention at that time. That's
interesting. I can't imagine there's a relation.
Speaker 3: I just I just was
thought that was strange.
Speaker 1: But yes, I don't know anything about.
Speaker 3: Thank you for the time, sir.
Speaker 1: Pleasure, appreciate
the call very, very much